support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on my
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so up until
recently we've talked about how atomic
theory has sort of developed over the
years but now we're going to talk about
modern atomic theory so we'll start with
the structure of the atom specifically
so let's go over a few notes atoms are
electrically neutral that's one thing
that we need to know right they have no
charge talk more about that in just a
second another thing is that as you can
see to the right here atoms are shaped
like spheres I've drawn a circle but you
can just imagine that in 3d and we'll
get to that in just a second another
thing that atoms contain three subatomic
particles which we've actually mentioned
already
I'll show them here protons neutrons and
electrons okay and these these subatomic
particles are often represented by these
little short hands where protons will be
P plus P with a plus sign to indicate
that they have a positive charge
neutrons and to the zero indicating they
have no charge electrons being a minus
which I think we've seen before okay now
let's look to the right here and we can
see that in the center here we've got
the nucleus which of course let's kind
of ugly let's try that again this is the
nucleus which of course contains the
protons here in green which are
positively charged b-plus right there
and the gray things with a little zeroes
those are the neutrons okay
protons and the neutrons are in the
center in the nucleus and they're
therefore called nucleons right because
they were inside the nucleus okay now
outside of the nucleus is where the
electrons hang out and I've sort of
shown them out here as along the dotted
line they can they can exist in this
this space here which is actually called
the electron cloud sometimes
and where they'll exactly be I'm not
going to really talk about now that's
something that we'll see later for now
we'll just kind of say that protons and
neutrons are in the nucleus whereas
electrons are outside the nucleus okay
now I mentioned that protons have
positive charged electrons have a
negative charge they have a relative
charge of protons of having +1 electrons
being minus 1 which is why they're
electrically neutral right if and
specifically specifically it's that the
number of protons the number of protons
equals the number of electrons so we
think about the number of positive
charges and the number of equal and
opposite negative charges is equal so we
have overall no charge right and of
course neutrons don't have charge ok so
that's their relative charges their
absolute charges are in coulombs and
those are listed here we're not gonna
really need those right now but those
are numbers that we can reference later
for certain certain types of problems
and their their masses here so we've got
relative mass and absolute mass absolute
mass being in grams we've seen grams
before so those are just numbers that
are listed there I'm not going to really
talk more about them there's more
reference values but the relative mass
there in AMU and amu stands for atomic
mass unit and we're not going to really
define that quite yet we're going to
talk about that in another video but for
now what we would kind of what I kind of
want you to pay attention to is that
protons and neutrons have approximately
the same mass right the same the same
mass here the relative masses they're
both approximately 1 right neutrons are
a little bit more massive than protons
but both of their relative masses are
approximately 1 they're about the same
have about the same mass you can
actually see that here in absolute class
they're really really close in terms of
their masses
whereas electrons are about a thousand
of that that value of that one and so
they're not very massive at all and so
generally speaking protons and neutrons
pretty much account for the mass
than Adam okay now another thing I do
want to mention is kind of the size and
the size differences here the nucleus is
about 10 to the negative 15 meters which
is a femtometer okay really really tiny
now the diameter of the entire atom is
about 10 to the negative 10 meters and
that's actually there's actually a
particular name for that as well it's
angstrom one angstrom the angstrom has
the unit or the letter a with a little
circle on top of it so this is generally
speaking of course not all atoms are the
same size but generally speaking it's
about its upon the order of these these
values so what does this kind of mean
well 10 to the negative 10 versus head
in area 15 that means that the diameter
of the entire atom is about 100,000
times 100,000 times the size of the
nucleus right the diameter of the
nucleus that's kind of insane so with
that that means is that this this area
outside the nucleus really is mostly
empty space the analogy that some people
like to use is that if you put a marble
in the middle of a football stadium or a
soccer stadium that's kind of and then
the rest of the space is where the
electrons can flow right the marble
would represent the nucleus every the
space outside of it would be the space
for the electrons can flow that's kind
of how it would be so it's really mostly
empty space and this drawing is not to
scale right um if we if the item
actually was had this diameter it would
be a really really really tiny dot
inside here that I probably so small
that I couldn't even draw using this
program but the point is that atoms are
mostly empty space and I hope that that
kind of makes sense for now about the
structure of the atom how we look at it
with modern atomic theory so hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to hit with a like and subscribe
for more content also follow a few
diversity on the different social media
links in the description below thanks
and happy studying